and we talked about just his usage is
different he's so much more comfortable
another pass assist from young
and the hammer from levine don't jump
and he looks fresh this happened so fast
we didn't even catch the culprit
he got out of there quick who's that guy
dumped on
oh sorry about that keelan martin caleb
martin
who quickly lost confidence on my jumper
oh levine gets the crowd fired up
test better shot but zach levine
with the highlight
i mean that is just beautiful levine's
played 21 minutes 16 points four
rebounds
again after missing those elections
bulls looked to run the other night
against toronto they got out in
transition
oh roby wasn't looking for the ball
sadaransky's got it
go get it oh my flight
eight do you have your ticket
[Applause]
whoa sato soto threw it up there baby go
get it eight go get it
watch this ladies and gentlemen watch
this shadow throws it to the rim
fly young man flies
perfect pass thunderous dunk
a thunder time-out 8-2 start
sets up the one-on-one with carter now
meets more bodies and carter
comes up with a rejection levine in
transition
with the right-handed mammoth hammer
he was 10 were there defensively for
philadelphia nine to shoot for chicago
and watch this he starts teeing it up
right here right here he's looking at
wait for that goal
and then the dunk what a finish but he
got his steps right
early he was just waiting for seth curry
to go for that steal
he even look and saw danny green most
improved player
and a first-team first-time all-star
last year
levine again
that time a little mix-up defensively
oh man well the offenses man you could
smile and say the offenses or shake your
head and talk about d
but the offenses are getting it done wow
it's act levine we talked about zion and
zach
he just blows right by hernan gomez the
rockets have
kind of slowed down oh well there's the
turnover right there it's getting ready
to say nice pass ahead
zach levine oh showtime from levine
[Applause]
give you a little highlight reel get
this man back in the dunk contest
i was just thinking that's a
contest-worthy
application a lot of time left
three possession games zach levine all
the way oh
mitchell robinson
a thunder it zach levine
with 24 points five rebounds seven
assists had been quiet for most of this
fourth quarter
until this jam
eyes popping out still a five point game
enforcement's now man okay that's the
big time stuff from our friends and
points
[Music]
[Applause]
so smart and he just sees that little
subtle move
by joshua kogi to get into his cut to
take away the dribble handoff to make it
more difficult for zach levine
as soon as zach sees that
here he is splitting the double taking
it to the rim
get up and get out the way watch this
right here he's going to split the
double team right there
and plummy was stuck in the mud and then
look at the look at the athleticism
levine's got the rebound he missed the
first two meetings against the bulls so
first opportunity for hayes
to face this rival watch your hand
stuart
vibin the hammer oh hammer don't hurt
him
boy isaiah stewart says he just blows
right by killing hayes nobody comes over
to help
and by the time stewart recognizes it he
said no i'm making a business decision
there's no way in the world i'm getting
ready to jump up here and
nope nope can't do it can't do it
we saw this early against boston too and